(audience cheering)
- Hello, everyone.
Thank you, thank you very much.
Welcome to "The Kelly Clarkson Show".
Obviously, I'm not Kelly.
I love me some Kelly, though.
I wish I was Kelly Clarkson.
She unfortunately is a
little under the weather
and since I'm around,
right around the corner
I was happy to step in
as today's guest host.
(audience cheers)
So thank you for having me in the show.
Of course, it always starts with music
and today is not gonna be any different.
Here's Kelly and her band Y'all,
with Post Malone's "Better Now".
(audience cheers)
♪ You probably think
that you are better now ♪
♪ Better now ♪
♪ You only say that
'cause I'm not around ♪
♪ Not around ♪
♪ You know I never meant to let you down ♪
♪ Let you down ♪
♪ Woulda gave you anything ♪
♪ Woulda gave you everything ♪
♪ Whoa ♪
♪ I did not believe
that it would end, no ♪
♪ Everything came second to the Benzo ♪
♪ You're not even speaking
to my friends, no ♪
♪ You knew all my uncles
and my aunts though ♪
♪ And I'm rolling,
rolling, rolling, rolling ♪
♪ With my brothers like
it's Jonas, Jonas ♪
♪ Drinking Henny and I'm tryna forget ♪
♪ But I just can't get you outta my head ♪
♪ You probably think
that you are better now ♪
♪ Better now ♪
♪ You only say this
'cause I'm not around ♪
♪ Not around ♪
♪ You know I never meant to let you down ♪
♪ Let you down ♪
♪ Woulda gave you anything ♪
♪ Woulda gave you everything ♪
♪ You know I say that I am better now ♪
♪ Better now ♪
♪ I only say that 'cause
you're not around ♪
♪ Not around ♪
♪ You know I never meant to let you down ♪
♪ Let you down ♪
♪ Woulda gave you anything ♪
♪ Woulda gave you everything, ♪
♪ Whoa ♪
♪ And I'm rolling,
rolling, rolling, rolling ♪
♪ With my brothers like
it's Jonas, Jonas ♪
♪ Drinking Henny and I'm tryna forget ♪
♪ But I just can't get
this outta my head ♪
♪ You probably think
that you are better now ♪
♪ Better now ♪
♪ You only say that
'cause I'm not around ♪
♪ Not around ♪
♪ You know I never meant to let you down ♪
♪ Let you down ♪
♪ Woulda gave you anything ♪
♪ Woulda gave you everything ♪
♪ Whoa ♪
- Hey.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah.
It's a jam right there.
One more time, give it up again
for Kelly and her band Y'all.
(audience cheers)